the family of john atkinson who died in
the manchester arena bombing have
refused to accept the apology of an
ambulance chief over the delays that
some doctors say contributed to his
death john was badly injured in the
blast four years ago but lay on the
floor of the arena's foyer for almost an
hour before paramedics arrived experts
have told the public inquiry that
earlier treatment could have saved him a
short time ago his family's lawyer read
a statement on their behalf
john was our son brother uncle and
friend
he was kind
intelligent
and would light up any room he walked
into
everyone who knew him loved being around
him his caring nature led him always to
put others first
he was the best uncle to his nephews
most caring of sons and brothers
he worked with young adults with autism
and he looked forward to being a foster
father
since his untimely passing our lives
have been shattered
as we try to live with the massive void
he used to fill
we have so many questions
that we hope the inquiry can help to
answer
we lost our beloved john to an appalling
atrocity whilst on a night out
an atrocity which could and should have
been prevented by proper security
to compound this
john was badly let down by some
mistake after mistake was made
and precious time was allowed to ebb
away
whilst john needed urgent hospital
treatment
this should never have been allowed to
happen
john had so much more to give
we heard the apology last week from mr
smith from the north west ambulance
service
we cannot accept this apology
actions speak louder than words
and we want to see what actions are
taken
to ensure that this never happens again
finally
we would like to thank those who tried
to help john in his time of need
ronald blake in particular is a hero
hearing about the kindness of strangers
on the night
has offered us a small glimmer of hope
in our darkest moments thank you
well let's head to the court in
manchester and join sky's innsman
rasheed who's been listening to the
evidence and intimate details of what
happened to john desperately sad
yeah they really are but look that's the
epitome of this inquiry jonathan to get
to the bottom of what happened on the
night of the 22nd of may
2017 the inquiry is trying to find out
exactly the details of what happened
that evening and that includes some of
the horrific details of those victims
the 22 who were blown up by salman abadi
at the manchester arena and this one in
particular is incredibly poignant
because john atkinson 28 years old a
care worker from berry greater
manchester could have survived and it's
down to the fact that paramedics that
ambulance services were so short in
terms of the numbers they couldn't get
in to help save lives now the details
that came out throughout the inquiry it
was a few days of evidence given the
final day today revealed how john
atkinson was severely injured from uh
from the bomb he was only six meters
away from salman abadi when he detonated
his device and he received serious
injuries to his legs now those legs were
tourniqueted by um someone who was in
the arena at the time but there was no
expert medical attention given to john
atkinson for at least 47 minutes that
meant his injuries that were already
incredibly serious became even worse he
was then stretched out on a makeshift
stretcher an advertising board
around 58 minutes later and it was an
hour and 20 minutes until john atkinson
was actually in an ambulance receiving
uh some some specific and expert medical
attention that meant that it was too
much of a toll on his body and he
suffered from a cardiac arrest he is
just one of the 22 victims and one
pointing that we heard could have
survived the manchester arena attack
four years ago now we heard uh evidence
given from a number of people one person
in particular ronald blake he was
mentioned in the family statement a
statement where the family say they
cannot accept the apology of northwest
ambulance service but ronald blake
actually stayed with mr atkinson for 58
minutes in total by his side he was on
the phone to emergency services telling
them about mr atkinson's situation
at the time but as i mentioned in that
statement we heard from the family
lawyer not accepting the apology from
northwest ambulance service this is what
dan smith the commander from nwas had to
say to the inquiry last week
mr atkinson's death will
remain with his family for a very long
time and and i am truly sorry if any
decision that i made any decision
impacted on his survivability
now john atkinson when he was with
paramedics eventually was pleading with
them he said please don't let me die
reminding them that he was in severe
pain from the injuries of the bomb as
they tried to take him to ambulance
services and then to hospital but there
was pure chaos
on that night and as ambulance service
struggled to get inside the foyer of the
manchester arena it meant dozens of
people hundreds of people were severely
injured from that attack but this again
one story of the 22 victims that died
that night and the story of jen atkinson
at this inquiry coming to a close today
but with that poignant statement from
the family directly saying that they do
not accept the apology but also pointing
out the heroes on the night that were
there with mr atkinson so yes some very
sad details jonathan but the inquiry
continues and we will hear more evidence
of other people who sadly died four
years ago at the manchester arena
attacks